- Ici, c'est en cinq.
Notre patient, madame...
- Chaque jour, Ludovic est
jumelé à des infirmières
formatrices.
- Vous n'avez pas de douleur?
Tout va bien?
- Arrivé de France
l'été dernier, on l'aide
à s'adapter en douceur.
LUDOVIC NEVEU,
infirmier recruté en France
- Ça me rassure de savoir
que, bien, l'équipe est là
et je ne suis pas tout seul.
- Comme toutes les recrues
d'ici ou d'ailleurs, il sera
accompagné pendant deux ans.
ANICK ST-ONGE, infirmière,
Hôpital du Centre-de-la-Mauricie
- On vient voir, au courant
des deux premières années,
à savoir quelles sont
les difficultés à l'entrée,
quels sont les éléments
qu'on peut mettre en place,
comment on peut venir adoucir
un petit peu leur entrée,
à ces nouvelles embauches-là.
- C'est toujours bon, hein,
ce que m'on mange?
- Oui.
- Ludovic était courtisé
par plusieurs régions,
mais il a choisi Shawinigan,
parce qu'on lui offrait
de l'aide pour s'établir
avec sa famille.
- C'est Ludovic!
De savoir qu'il y a tout
un organisme qui est là
pour nous aider, pour nous
accompagner, pour nous
supporter, bien c'est important.
Dans le choix de venir,
c'est même décisif.
- C'est la grande séduction pour
attirer non pas des médecins,
mais plutôt des infirmières.
Les candidatess locales se font
offrir, dès le début de leur
cours en sciences infirmières,
un poste de préposée,
payant pour l'étudiante
et pour l'établissement.
ANTRANIK HANDOYAN, dir., RH,
CIUSSS Mauricie-Centre-du-Québec
- Les candidates à l'exercice
de la profession qui viennent
chez nous, qui font ce parcours-
là, notre taux de rétention
est au-delà de 90 %.
Et c'est payant.
(bips du moniteur cardiaque)
- Le CIUSSS de Mauricie-Centre-
du-Québec a réussi à ajouter
546 infirmières à son effectif
depuis deux ans. Mais pour
éliminer le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire, la direction doit
continuer à embaucher.
- Pour contrer le temps
supplémentaire obligatoire,
ça prend aussi des gens
sur le terrain. C'est un peu
un cercle vicieux, tout ça.
- L'un des établissements
qui semblent avoir brisé
le cercle vicieux est le CHUM,
à Montréal.
- Ici, à l'urgence au CHUM,
d'ailleurs, on n'a pas de temps
supplémentaire obligatoire.
- Fini, le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire. Pour y arriver,
on a su recruter et retenir
les effectifs. L'hôpital
a réussi un ajout net
de 410 infirmières depuis
deux ans, d'abord en offrant
des horaires plus prévisibles.
KARELL BOSSÉ, infirmière-chef
de l'urgence, CHUM
- Dans l'urgence, nous,
ce qu'on a mis en place,
c'est l'autoplanification.
L'autoplanification
des horaires, c'est
la possibilité... on donne
la possibilité à l'équipe de
dire deux mois avant l'horaire,
de dire : "Bien, moi, j'aimerais
ça travailler telle journée,
telle journée, telles journée,
et avoir congé telle journée
et telle autre journée."
- À quelle heure?
- Le CHUM a aussi instauré des
quarts de travail de 12 heures.
- Les 12 heures, c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui va faire qu'on
peut comprimer l'horaire. Donc,
exemple, une personne qui fait
un temps complet, donc 10 jours
semaine, elle va le faire
en sept jours. Donc, ce que ça
fait, c'est que tu travailles
sept jours, tu fais complètement
tes heures de temps complet,
mais t'as sept jours de congé.
Tu peux avoir une meilleure
qualité de vie.
- Je vais recontrôler
votre saturation.
- Sébastien affirme
qu'il quitterait le CHUM
si on le forçait à faire
des heures supplémentaire.
SÉBASTIEN ALIX, infirmier, CHUM
- Bien oui, moi, la dernière
fois que j'ai fait ça,
c'était en 2013.
- Merci! Au revoir.
- Abolir le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire semble
incontournable pour retenir
les infirmières de la nouvelle
génération.
- La direction a décidé
d'abolir le temps supplémentaire
obligatoire, chose qui
est merveilleuse pour
les infirmières quand même,
parce que là, maintenant,
on peut rentrer travailler
sans avoir peur de pas avoir
à repartir après notre quart
de travail.
- Ici Davide Gentile,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.